W
MORE NEW CAV THANIN T T
PANDEMIC.MO
U.S. A WITH CORONAN APRIL, THAT
THOUGHT WAS THES
NOWN DWARFTE ALONE AMONG WHYWES
SEEING THE CURVE TRENDING IN THE
WRONION.DR. ANTHONYAU DAY
HALF THE COURY  LOC ISTO, MEANS
IT THIS, OF CO
AYS WHILE SUPPO
STATES P BACK PAUSI SAID, E,
TN,
THEE IDGLAS ALL
EMPIRI FAILING.
AS CNN'SON REP NOW,S FULLY
STATING THE UNITED STATES ISNVI
>> WHILE CORAVIRUS CASES OUNTRYE
POTENTIALLY THE VACCINE>> ALL T
AL TO HAVE A
VACCINE TT IS SAFE
BY THE END L
BY ONE OF >>
CANDIDATES.
WE'VE HAD MANY MORE BUT THREE A.
>> THAT NEWS COMES THE
SA A SINGLE DAY RECORD FOR NEW
CASENWEDNESDAY.
JUST T REPORTIHA  NEWSES, A
NEW DAILY R FOR
STATE. CLS
IS BECOMING LESND  W RN OF A DI
EVERYONE DREDDIE DAY  OVERWHELM
THE MANY IN SHERE ARE WA FOR
>> I GPEOPLE,
EXCELLCANDES
THEY ARE S SICK DON'T GET ONK L
PLANS DUE TOPIKES IN COVID CASE.
TODAY THEON TOPEXPERT TELLI
M OPENEDE UNITED STATES EVE
THE MOST STRICT LOCKDOWN 50% OF.
THAT ALLOWED THE PER PETUATRPET
>> CASINOS OPE THE STOPPG ALABAS
SOLD TE TO THESON O
WINS . TUNATELY I DON'T BELIEVED
ESPECIALLY IN
TUSCALOOSA, AND PRO LIKE A
LOT OF CASES IN  THE HAS OMN HO
COTYTING CLUSTERNK PARTY.COUNTY
ANDOM
TOK CONTACT TRACE
HE HEALTH O
CO BECAUSE
OF IGNORA STUPIDITY OR
>> DR. FAUCI ASKED IF THE U WIT
CORONAVIRUS.>> YOU'VE BEEN LOS ?
W. GIVE UAUSE IPEARS WE'RE LOS.
AE MORE FROMUC.
HENT TALKED MORE ABOUT
POTENTIAL FOR
PROJECTIONS GOING FORWARD.
HE SAID TY SHOULD KNO
WINTER OR EARLY2021 THEY
HAVE AAFECCCINE.
ALREADJA T
DISCUS HEALT HO WOULD BE THE
TO GRESPONDERS, POSSIBLY THOSE
U EFFECTIVE VA
JAKE.
THAT'S RIGHT.
JASON CARROLL, THANKOMUCH.
LET'S BRING C CED
CORRESPONDENT DR SAN GUPTA.
NEW STUDY SHOWS THERE NEW OF TU
INFECTIOUS BUT JUST AS
IFAD YOU TELL UHE L IS THEOS
IT MAKES IT MORE
SPREAD, IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO
MAKE IT MORE
JAE HAD SOME HINTS OF THIS
BEFORE.
W AAINARILY ASIA AND A
DIFFERENT STRANT PRIMARILY OUT
OF EUROPE. PARTF
THE UNITED ATSUS WESTERN
UNITED STATES, PROBABLY IONS OFS
WERE ATITHEA AATNWHAT IS KNOWN
PROTEIS THEROTEIN THAT ALL VIR E
MORE EASILY INSIDE T
I  TWORIS
IS WHILE ITAKE I SPRE I  LETHALS
THE COUNTRY LOOK  HEARI TODAY
R SU JUST BE
TO MORE >> THERE IS NO QUESTEST
BELIEVE THIS REALREASE
ASHE PERCENT IFTSNG S IS.
>>T'OMEBODY
TELLING THE TRUTH ABOUT T NEWS D
WANT TO THAT
>> THAT ISIOUSLY DIRECT POSITIOA
CETHE NARRATIVE HAS BEE TEST
MORE, YOU'RE GOING FDCA MK
UNTER-INTUITIVE BUTS
YOU  ULTIMATELY YOU
SHOULD H LESS, FEWER YOULATEPEO
QUARANTINE THEM AND THAT'S HOW
YOUAK THE TRANSMISSION
SP
I DON'KNVE THE
GRAPHS OF TEXAS SEE WE'VE LOOKE.
WE KNOW THE NUMBER OF CASES A I.
WHAT'S ALSO BEEN HAPPENIHEREIS
HIGH,D 15
OR SO OVEREW DAYS.
THAT'S TOOAT MEANS AS TESTING T
>> AY, DCI
OW TOD THE M MESSAGIN FROLY D O
THE PANDE MIGHT HAVE
U.S. BHAT THE U.S.
NEVER REALLY SHU YOU
DURING THE SHUTDNT UER
HOWRE YOUER RIGHT  VIRUS?
WELL, YOOW REALIZE, KEAVTOOLS,
THEY CAN M BIG
DR. AND OTHERS M'SCE
ATEGINNING OF THE VIRUS
THERE S A LOTN'T KNOW.
IT WAS NOVEL CORONAVIRUS.
THINGS W BEIALWAY. SOME PRETTY
50% OF THEOU RY
SHUT DOWN.
THAT'S A PROBLEM B
COUNTRIES DID SHU A
TREMENDOUS SUCCESS. SHOULDOPEN?U
TO HAVE 14 DAYSNWDE YOU STAOPEN.
HERE,  DS TEXAS OPENED.HE , HE
EPA MAY 1st M 30th.
JAKE, THE NUMBEPE FLVES.
TH I PTHE REASON WE'RE
IN THIS PROBLEM.
PART OF THOSE GUIDESO UP IN AEE.
SOME STATEHOSEKS AS WELL.
E SHOULD POINT  SANJAY,
YOU AND I W ATH
WERE REOPENING, EVEN THOUGH THEY
WERE VIOLATINGLL OF THE N FROM
CORONAVIRUS TASKFORCE, WE WERE
YIY HAD N THERE WE ARE WITH AN
EXOS H DEATHS.HASON YOU H
THEERIA.
IT SEEMS LIK
OUT THE WINDOWUICKLY AS
THEY WERE RE
THEY WERE PU T HEE
BUT YOU DON'T REALLY HAV TTHEM.
THSON WANT14-D
MANAGEABLEEVIN
IF Y G MANAGEATHNE, CONTACTTRLL
OF THAT.
WIHERS AS HIGH A
TOUGH TO DO,
>> HEARING
TODAY, A HEALTH HUMAN SENGHE EFI
MO CORONAVIRUS VACCIN NEXT YEAR?
ARE YOU  AM.
ISSEEP AREA OF WE'VEEE TALKING
ABOU IS, HEAD OF  NIH, BEG OPTT.
THARNT
VACCIN PLATFORMS BEING WORKED
SOME ARE PROGRESSINGOR
HES KIND OF AZTHINK THIS ILE OF
JAAC INNAT
WILLE FOREVER ACCELERATED BY
THIS PANDIC.WE HAV WEEKS  TOOK E
ST
RE AGAINST THE ORCES
INNOVA.E, OF
THE PLATFORM VACCI IC REALLY S
WITHIN DAY